parking lot after school is all teachers
don't fight nah my mom what's your
emergency
there's a crazy guy at my high school
he's trying to beat me up if you have a
problem with a bully I need to speak to
a teacher
no I am a teacher excuse me
it's actually another teacher who wants
to have a fight with me after school so
I need help
oh very funny you're gold man now gonna
take that ass-whooping ha ha
why are you trying to pick a fight with
me man these students the [ __ ] on this
school all day you think this is funny
i'ma show you what's fun radical he did
it now you got to pay the price snitches
get stitches what you talking about
mr. Strickland reputation of a hothead
scary yet effective yeah
am I the only one here who sees what's
going on at all hello hello you hello
he's holding an axe
[Music]
mr. Campbell
English teacher probably a nice guy but
a bit of a worm and a sneak you guys in
Strickland who's gonna fight Campbell
yeah he's gonna whip on bad two teachers
are in a school fight to end all school
fights your brother's teachers fight a
fight
the whole schools into it we're gonna
tailgate
actions have consequences
this school is crazy
[ __ ] is violent I look like a million
lunatic teachers oh you're the guidance
counselor you're not doing meth again
right mmm yeah yeah there's a little bit
don't do meth cuz it's a gateway it's
the finish line it's gone down he's a
nice guy and then people are like hey
I'm gonna stomp on that guy I'm done
with this [ __ ] no more mr. nice guy
no we're playing by the rules careful
daddy's gotta get in a fist fight
Campbell you got this I don't think he's
got this why don't you just take a punch
and then just go down wait dad like
possums do or anything that's like a
like a [ __ ] animal
Oh
I'm gonna fight you I'm sorry what
parking lot after school its own
teachers don't fight I want everybody to
see this
[Applause]
hashtag teacher fight couse knows
matheson I don't need to be light I need
to educate
I just don't know the first thing about
fighting makeup first
are you serious this stuff 1700s oh
maybe the best thing to do is just run I
never said nothing about no running
who's you see this game flex I am
flexing just nothing there why I just
take punch and then just go down
play dead like possums do or anything
that's like a like a [ __ ] animal now
I'm along with emergency there's a crazy
guy in my high school he's trying to
beat me up if you have a problem with a
bully I need to speak to a teacher I am
a teacher
you're Goldman not gonna take that ass
whuppin
you
you